weaving and knitting to create fabrics  are some of our oldest forms of  technology now those ancient practices  have become high-tech manufacturing and  they're meeting up with cutting-edge  robotics to create artificial muscles  these textile actuators or textures are  made from cellulose yarn instead of dye  the yarn is coated with a material  called poly pyrrole that moves in  response to electricity  the textures can be woven or knitted  woven forms can exert more force but the  knitted ones can stretch and change  shape the fabric can be tweaked to give  the right balance of stretchiness and  strength this new fabric is designed to  be manufactured at industrial scales the  technology could be integrated into  potential assistive devices like  prosthetics or exoskeletons one day  artificial muscles made of fabric could  be integrated into clothing to aid  mobility  [Music]